hey it happened again when I tell you
that there was a glimmer of reason on
Fox News it's almost always chef Smith
and once again chef Smith has told
simple basic truths about the Trump
North Korea summit and the Fox News
audience is calling for his head the Fox
News audience is furious that this non
apologia from the Trump administration
has taken place on none other than
propaganda machine Fox News Shep Smith
in very simple terms said listen
Singapore summit between Crump and Kim
jong-un Trump gave Kim jong-un
everything and he got nothing in return
it's the correct analysis it's a simple
analysis and it's a very out of place
analysis on Fox News which has been
cheerleading the summit as some kind of
masterful example of historic
geopolitical diplomacy ingenious by
Donald Trump check out Fox and Shep
Smith's very basic and uncontroversial
coverage which had Fox viewers calling
for his firing right away a really
fantastic meeting a lot of progress
really very positive I think better than
anybody could have expected the United
States made concessions in exchange for
no hard promises stopping joint military
exercises with South Korea while North
Korea makes a vague commitment to work
together toward denuclearization the
agreement the leaders side is very short
on specifics we'll look at what really
came out of the summit in Singapore and
what happens next so that's his tease
and then during the actual story going
in even harder on this and again nothing
he's saying is controversial in the
normal world but on Fox News this
apparently is considered it's almost
treasonous if you look at the online
comments no specifics President Trump
and Kim signed a joint statement after
almost five hours of talks and in the
document the North Korean leader quote
reaffirmed his firm and unwavering
commitment to complete denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula no specifics of
how to do it no timeline on getting it
done no verification no inspection no
nothing else just generalities this went
on and it was a really actually
good report it was an accurate report
and it led to theory fury against Shep
Smith online people immediately coming
up with the F word because Shep is gay
and right away it's like they ignore the
fact that he's gay when he's toeing the
party line and all of a sudden Shep says
hey you know what Trump gave up a bunch
of stuff and didn't get anything back
now all of a sudden Shep sexual
orientation is actually relevant to his
reporting skills I was like yeah you
really got him there what an insult I'm
sure he's gonna lose sleep over that I
still think that he's there and allowed
to do whatever he wants to create a way
for Fox to say hey we've got diversity
of opinion we've got everybody and then
Shep Smith actually said something
different about the the Singapore summit
and there's actually a bigger issue here
that the North Korea summit made me
think of and this is I hope you'll
you'll sort of see the connection
political partisanship is leading not to
strange bedfellows but to bedfellows
that are completely antithetical to the
political beliefs that people claim to
have there's examples on the left and on
the right let's look at an example from
the right or a couple Vladimir Putin and
Kim jong-un before Trump Putin was an
oppressive authoritarian Kim jong-un was
a brutal dictator who hadn't earned a
seat at the table with an American
president because of his brutality Trump
comes in and all of a sudden the same
right-wingers especially the ones that
have become committed trumpets start
saying for example we should get along
with any country that wants to meet with
us what's wrong with negotiating we have
to get past our differences to try to
negotiate for the better which they
didn't say before Trump they didn't say
when it was Obama thinking about who he
might sit down with be it Iran or
anybody else total reversal totally
antithetical to their stated political
beliefs that's the right the left is not
innocent here okay I've talked before
about as a result of this political
rabbit hole that some on the Left have
been pulled down you end up seeing
supposed progressive leftists de-facto
defending Vladimir Putin I've talked
about that some on the Left have started
issuing defenses of serious Syria's
brutal dictator Bashar al-assad
rationalizing it in ways that
make absolutely no sense we've seen
elements of the left idolizing foe
populist authoritarians Hugo Chavez and
Nicolas Maduro of Venezuela and I've
even seen some tacit defenses from some
on the left of Hamas one of the most
extreme religious terrorist groups in
the world and if you don't fall down the
rabbit hole in one fell swoop it tends
to happen gradually and that's what's
really scary we've seen this gradual
decline in two individuals on the left
and right defending extremism and bad
ideas you don't go from Putin is bad to
total indifference about Russian
manipulation of our president overnight
right it happens a little bit at a time
same thing with these defenses that
we're seeing of Kim jong-un and I've
talked before about having a set of
principles that you believe in that's
important but the real world is made
more complex by having to figure out how
do you apply the principles to specific
situations what's happened with some on
the right with Putin and Kim jong-un and
some on the left with Putin and Chavez
and Maduro and Bashar al-assad is that
the principles have been totally
abandoned beyond all reason and logic
and it's scary because it proves that
almost anyone can be bamboozled into
defending stuff they wouldn't ever
imagined themselves defending if you
were to have asked them to three or even
five years ago about it I want to hear
from you about this what do you think of
my analysis of this phenomenon that has
been observed on both the left and the
right